[Applause]
welcome back uh today we have with us
somebody
i grew up thinking of as a legend when i
first started out on wall street i had a
ritual on saturday mornings i'm going to
be really old here on saturday mornings
i would walk to the newsstand and pick
up my copy of barons
and read it
and
uh
and that it hasn't gone away i just now
do it online like the rest of us well
like the most of us
um but i'm pleased to introduce uh
randall randall forsythe i call him
randy associate editor at barron's which
used to be a weekly but it's now pretty
much a 24 7 news operation and he is
also the columnist who is responsible
for up and down wall street which many
people watching will understand exactly
what that column is welcome oh thank you
so much thank you i'm privileged to be
here
uh so before we started taping you you
mentioned that you had quite the
esteemed
next-door neighbor when it comes to
where you grew up well
not not while i was growing up but i
actually grew up a block away i believe
from where alan greenspan
spent the early years of his childhood
but
later he moved somewhere else in the
neighborhood but he also went to the
same local high school
up in northern northern tip of manhattan
george washington high school the same
as my mother
the same as
people like
baseball greats rod crew
manny ramirez
and
also henry kaufman the the esteemed
economist but we all grew up the
northern end of washington in washington
heights in manhattan which
i feel growing up there
gives you great preparation and great
incentive to get the hell out
well but
that being said it clearly produced
quite a few economists yes well it was
then also a center of a lot of
people
german jewish
refugees
fleeing nazi germany in the 30s who who
moved up there and
in any case it became known as like
little frankfurt or something like that
but uh that that was where i grew up and
but uh i i don't know i i just feel a
kinship
i think greenspan was on 163rd street i
was on 164th
why economics why did why did you choose
to go down that path
it was something that i was always
interested in also i
i didn't do very well in organic
chemistry and
i and math
math i barely got through
elementary calculus and all the sciences
were too hard so i switched to economics
which was what i was really interested
in anyway and it just seemed to make
sense to me from
uh intuitively from um
when i was a kid so
that's where work came from and it was
something
that that i could i could grasp and i
felt like i could explain
well being able to explain something is
pretty critical if you're going to go on
to write about it
not every economist i run across
goes on to start their career
in a newspaper well i i don't consider
myself an economist i
consider myself a reporter first
and i got into it because
another
tie from my childhood my aunt was one of
the first
female business journalists in the
country claire record who wrote for the
new york times free
for years and years and
that
it gave me sort of a glimpse into uh
into the business and i thought it was a
pretty neat way to make a living so
i kind of followed that i
had my first job
at the times
i wholeheartedly
endorsed nepotism so i was i was hired
as a copy boy
and
in in 1970 and
it was just a great time i was
there when you know people you know
there was a big shout in the newsroom
when
uh the decision on the pentagon papers
came down and
things things of that sort but uh
i was in the business section which was
a little bit different
and
was frankly considered a backwater then
was not
an important
part it wasn't seen as as something as
part of the political world
or
or really anything else but very kind of
parochial
and people who business reporters then
in general did not have any kind of uh
background in in economics
or so they weren't all nyu or columbia
journalism school graduates far from it
they were probably
i've frankly a lot of them were rejects
from other departments and uh we're
stuck there
but um i was you know
early on there uh there was a change in
the kind of the professionalism i think
also everything in journalism changed
around around that time with ward with
watergate
and then reporters became a
kind of stars and so forth people went
to journalism school but also i noticed
that in in business that
the economy became a big story in the
70s with soaring inflation soaring
unemployment and it was then it became
front page news
the one exception i also remember from
um
working at the times and it was a great
help to me that one of the reporter's
name was eric heinemann he had i think
i'm pretty sure he had an mba he after
he left journalism he became a wall
street economist if
he was at morgan stanley at one point
and
other firms but um
he helped me and guided me and
after that um after being a copy boy
which essentially meant you you
you you move you shuffle help shuffle
papers or also
uh go
for the head of the copy desk you got
got to miss greasy burger and beer and
things like that and all all sorts of
other
kind of menial things but after a couple
of years
the assistant financial editor left
and went to a trade paper
called the bond buyer and he decided uh
exactly and
much much bigger than it was then
and he for some reason decided to hire
a 19 year old who hadn't finished
college as a beginning reporter there
so and
when the last thing when i left the
times when the reporter says
you're going to write about bonds
who would ever want to do that
so i went went to the bond buyer and
learned i i
finished most of my undergraduate
studies in economics so
i
i understood the theory behind it but
then i learned a about
how bonds work price up heel down
but mastering that little bit uh
gave me a career
so and then to write about it and
essentially i became an apprentice and
worked there for four years
and what year was that more or less
well i started there
my first byline
was in 1972.
it yes do the math
i was still a teenager though i had my
first byline on on the
the then new agency bond market
that in 1972
it was before nixon was even re-elected
no
watergate was still a third-rate
burglary that nobody was paying
attention to but
so i was there
and um
then i worked there for four years and
after that
somehow i i got hired away and i worked
for four years at merrill lynch
as
working on
essentially rewriting
analysts reports for
retail and the great attraction was that
it was a 33 percent raise over what i
was making
exactly and uh
i i was being young that they could pay
me less so in any case i was there for
four years when i realized i didn't want
to do this the rest of my life
and i really had a lot more fun
right
writing and reporting my own stuff so
thankfully i was uh hired
by dow jones to wall street the two wall
street journal bond reporters at the
time said hey you know
bonds and interest rates are a big story
away from just covering as all stocks
and earnings reports that are on the
regular dow jones ticker so they started
something covering
the capital markets so i was hired then
and i started covering uh treasury
market and the fed for them and that was
that was a lot more fun but merrill
lynch actually it was almost like a
graduate education apart from a formal
graduate education i saw the inside
of how
wall street and wall street research
worked so that was very educational
and why would that be i mean i know what
my experience when i was on the cell
side and boy did it open my eyes but
well you couldn't obviously you never
have a you never had a cell
recommendation
neutral was as as as good as cell
and
that
they took great pains to separate
um
or outwardly separate
investment banking clients from
from their stocks but
i never witnessed anything as egregious
as
shaping
i think where was it at smith barney
of a
rating on 18t to get your kid into a
posh
manhattan private school but
uh
there
i think wall street uh
most research is unavoidably compromised
so
um
it it's just
you can't you can't 50 years later
uh yeah probably
uh
a lot of regulations have been taking
place
there was a chinese wall there but uh
i'm
i would be uh surprised it would i like
they they said in casablanca i'm shocked
shocked that there might be
any conflict of interest
it's amazing how little things have
changed i mean there was a scandal just
a few years ago about
trying to get
toddlers into the
second street y yeah
yes
exactly but i also learned a lot i i
knew nothing about the the stock market
so i learned a lot there especially
um
i would get
bob farrell's writings every day
and the other people worked around him
and then i also made contact with a a
lot of people
in in
there there were different different
fiefdoms of uh bond research
but uh whether it was rates or credit or
things like that and and economics was
separate so they all had to be uh on the
same page but i met other people that i
still know i well
one name comes up is maria ramirez who
has her own firm and i talked to her
economist
and use his research
because i know maria and i know maria is
is is a straight shooter sure
well um so
mother merrell went away yes the great
financial crisis which brings us to the
whole idea of crisis oh yes i love
crises i've seen a few yes well uh
actually going back to my
first week at
the new york times in 1970s when penn
central went under
and what happened there just in case
somebody's not
oh well pen there was they used to
actually have a railroad
that was not government run
and uh it was
it was the the decline of railroads from
being the
the bulwark of the 19th century economy
and essentially they uh
they took on too much debt and they kept
selling a lot of commercial paper
that eventually they defaulted on
and
in the background the fed sort of
came to the rescue and set they couldn't
bail out penn central
or the the commercial paper holders but
they sort of told the banks to lend to
the
to the counterparties to and try to
smooth everything over and uh
and
and essentially eased money because of
of that that failure then uh
you had various ones you had the
the big uh thing that followed then was
the oil embargo that pushed us into
the first time we had high inflation
and uh high unemployment
so let's let's talk about that because
we have half of that equation
yes we do so what was it like back then
when he had this massive energy shock
it was
there there were i think there was a
fundamental change in everything all of
a sudden
uh things that we you took for granted
became unaffordable
the the my one recollection from them is
a strange thing
hamburger helper
everybo you know hamburger used to be
what was cheap and you could always
afford hamburger
but then hamburger all of a sudden got
so expensive you had to stretch it with
all with this extra
filling
so it it was a
first time i under i i saw
a pronounced decline in living standards
because everything cost more everything
was more difficult and that that's what
sticks with me uh until today and um
it's there there is a kind of a sense of
deja vu about that but we can come back
to that well and back then of course
this was kind of prior to the advent of
borrowing to get by this is this is
really before credit cards well they're
they extend your paycheck
yes there were there there were credit
cards but uh
you couldn't you couldn't use them at
the supermarket
so you got to
you you end up
getting to the checkout and you might
have to
take
take items out of the cart
i remember that so and
everything just kind of would leapfrog
ahead of
whatever you were making
whatever raise you got
the cost of a new car of a new house
of renting an apartment just kept
getting staying that much farther
out of reach were you aware at the time
of the federal reserve oh yes it was one
of the first things i did was
i would go to the
weekly new york fed meetings
and they would
have liberty yeah so one thing you
wouldn't um
you wouldn't know now is that when the
fed
changed policies it wasn't announced
you had to infer this from a whole
arcane bunch of open market operations
and at
what level
the fed came into the money market to
add or drain reserves
and there was a whole army of fed
watchers who tried to interpret all
these things it was like
most of them had worked at the fed they
knew
how the open market desk worked
and they were trying to interpret it
it's sort of like i i don't know
sort of
trying to figure out something behind a
curtain
and
it wasn't until uh greenspan raised
rates in
94
that um
that it was the action was actually
announced
when it happened the first statement yes
but up until then and there there were
incorrect interpretations occasionally
which roiled the markets and so forth
but
finally after 20-something years of my
learning how how to interpret all these
open market operations
which now i
i it's as useless knowledge is sort of
like
dos commands on
on the original pcs
it it wasn't very helpful so that they
did away with that but every week you go
to the
federal reserve and you poured over all
these different uh reports
over trying to figure out will they put
money in then and they took it out then
or whatever and also for a time then
what
the money supply did week to week
was what wall street would hang on
and so are
they it was given out
now it's of course post everything's
posted online but it was given out by a
bunch of sheets and at a
meeting at the new york fed at 3 30 on
thursdays
and they would distribute all this
and um
it was like a weekly ritual and then the
reporters would you know
get get to the phones and we were able
to call into their desks
and everything was released like at 4
15.
but it it
it was very interesting and it was like
a
a small fraternity and the best thing
about it is that i met my wife there
oh okay who was reporting for another
um for a trade organization
and um
the rest is history it was she she did a
lot better for herself by going into tv
later and being a cnn anchor well that's
interesting that brings me back around
alan greenspan and being married to a
reporter who was on tv yes well and
well yeah
more than greenspan uh she got to uh
interview uh treasury secretary james
baker just before the 1987
crash in not
october of that year
and really what
the story is that baker requested this
interview so he could make a statement
to the world that the at that time there
was sort of a an agreement to stabilize
currency exchange rates which meant
uh
having to
the
the country with a weak currency which
was the us then would have to raise
interest rates
and uh
when inflation was was rising but um
baker with the eye to the 1988 election
didn't want any more interest rate rises
and he he said so
and so kind of this whole
arrangement went kablooey and so you had
the dow jones industrial average dropped
22 percent
but
and it's all my wife's fault
did she buy that
oh no she was very upset that we we
missed it we we uh went on a long very
long deferred vacation right after she
did that interview
so we we found out about it was
and not bad being
reading about it in northern italy but
otherwise by the time we we saw the
financial times on tuesday
we couldn't believe it and she called
into her desk and said
it's all over forget it enjoy your
vacation so that she blames me for that
well but
between jerry corrigan and alan
greenspan yep
it seems like they put humpty dumpty
back together again pretty darn quickly
oh well that that's been uh kind of the
the modus operandi of for every crisis
ever ever since
if uh the financial markets shake and
quiver
um
ease money
well
back in the day and this is
this came out in in my book fed up
back then
alan greenspan was leaking information
to bond trading desks ahead of fed
injections and liquidity into the market
so it was a remarkable time in that it
came out in his in his biography that he
was always intimidated by the stock
market yes yes
and re-reading that biography now
um
he he thought the stock market
controlled just about everything about
about what businesses would do or invest
expand or not expand would depend on
where the stock market was which
seems to give the stock market a lot
more uh credit when you know
a the the economy runs more on credit
than and then equity and um
it just
the the central banks around the world
are enthralled now to um
financial markets
and they have been ever since alan
greenspan
since 87
especially but again there were fed
easings after um
in in the 70s like after penn central
now what was different in between there
was paul volcker
who withstood
everything including you know all sorts
of
uh threats and and and so forth to do
before it became a central bank mantra
whatever it takes
to bring down inflation
and
once we had
cpi style inflation
in control the the central bank
could take credit for it
and then come to the rescue every time
financial markets had a connection
and you know it was then again in
what i think was most egregious
was in
98
when
we had the
the previous russian debt crisis
and a lot of hedge funds were
wrong-footed
well a big hedge fund in particular
long-term capital markets and the rest
of wall street
were their counterparties so um
you know you know the old saying if
i owe a million
that's my problem with i owe you a
billion it's your problem so uh
even though the economy was cooking
we were pretty much at full employment
inflation wasn't
we certainly didn't have deflation in
anything but financial assets but the
fed
eased into a fully employed economy
and
so
you put a little flame on the fire and
then a couple of years later what do you
know you have a dot-com bubble
and
when that bubble bursts you start it all
over again and start easing again and
bring
bringing down
interest rates to
on a pre ever every cycle it's
previously unimaginable
levels
so
but uh yeah it's
lather rinse repeat
at what point did you cross over and
become part of barons well in the in the
early 80s jim grant
who everybody knows and esteems
yes
yes uh he was at barons at that point
he was writing uh the
he was and he was the originator of the
current yield column
and he was going to take a sabbatical to
write his first book i believe it was
about bernard baruch
in the interim he
he suggested that i
and another fellow working with me on
the dow jones capital markets report
one matthew winkler fill in for him
matt of course went on to found
bloomberg news and making it the
colossus it is today
and
i went to barrens
so
after a little while after jim
left to start uh grant's interest rate
observer uh alan abelson hired me
so um
let's let's talk a little bit about alan
abelson because
i mean he was
i don't i don't know if you could say
that there was a more
iconic
in the history of financial news yes i
i i would agree nobody had alan's style
again
now alan
did not have um
an economics degree or a journalism
degree he did however go to
the great
iowa
writers workshop
i think one of his contemporaries was
flannery o'connor there
and actually i think his undergraduate
degree was in biology
so i mean this was a very eclectic and
well-read mind and
nobody could express it like alan
he
he just
was was a great stylist and he was fun
to read and that that's something you
don't associate with business journalism
and then
and um it's definitely an inspiration to
me in that sense
i've wanted every piece of research that
comes out a quill to be fun to read in
the beginning or and certainly not not
boring so um he and he did not suffer
fools
uh lightly and he also
had kind of um the old-fashioned
he he grew up in the old-fashioned new
york
newspapers i think he was with the
journal american if anybody even
remembers that
but
he was kind of he
he hated
crooks and there were there were a lot
more
like
penny stock scams
in those days and he
loved ferreting them out
and he also um when he wasn't
what you didn't see
you saw what allen wrote in up and down
wall street
that was really
half of allen he was also editing the
rest of the paper
and put it putting his imprint on
a lot of stories
and also
nurturing a lot of
other writers and
i was lucky enough
to be one of them well he he also was
kind of a technophobe so you'd you'd
write these stories and in those days it
was
printed out on this dot matrix printer
and the stories it was like one big long
scroll and he would edit it with his
scroll in
in in the in the margins
and if you get it back and it was
just a mess of all of his his
in indecipherable handwriting he said oh
my god it's uh
i'm trying to think of a polite way to
put it you but you were you were taken
taken down a notch and if you didn't
when i when that happened to me early on
it was a great teaching experience
and after a while the scrolls in the
margin got let fewer and fewer and uh
so picturing those wax pencils those
thick wack wax pants no no it was it was
just a plain old
uh black ball point pen but but
with the i still remember the the dot
matrix little pr print and say and just
seeing
nothing nothing that what you had
written is
survived but it was all his scrolls
so uh at some point you were asked to
fill in
for alan
uh yes
later on later on first of all i i i i
stopped
writing for a while and became an
assistant managing editor
uh supervising uh the the market
coverage mainly
but
after a while that that got old and i
was itching to to write again
and um when alan
allen would go on vacation grudgingly
he he lived
he and he loved his column
so he in
2001 he
he decided to take toby in the summer he
wanted he's going to take a week off
finally and what i fill in
and of course i i was very excited by
the prospect
uh the week he picked to be off was the
week of the the tragedy of 9 11.
so that was my
uh kind of baptism of fire writing that
column and it was a one debut
yes and uh what do what do you say about
you know
to
certainly to that point the most
calamitous
uh event
in u.s history the only thing that i you
know anybody could compare it to was
pearl harbor but that did not happen in
downtown manhattan
at the heart of capitalism i think
people forget from the perspective of
financial markets history that the stock
market closed yes on tuesday morning it
reopened on my birthday which was a
monday but it closed and it stayed
closed
and that's something that hadn't
happened since world war one no it was
it was
every day the stock market didn't open
it was where we were being attacked all
over again
everything was frozen but i had to
somehow by
thursday night
it happened on a tuesday morning by
thursday night i had to
make some sense out of it
and uh
and never having done this for the for
any time
and the one thing i do recall saying was
that it was going to change things
and for
remember this was the cold war it ended
it was pax americana we had the peace
dividend and that i just thought that
was wrong we're going to have to spend a
lot more on
defense and security which would take
away from spending on all
sorts of fun stuff
i didn't expect a
few trillion dollars and
20 years in
the middle east to follow on to that but
that that is history
and here we are
exactly middle eastern backdrop
[Music]
so
bring us to where we are today
uh because we could talk about the
financial crisis
but you're right the fed is
wash rent's repeat
one of the things that was
that did change
was in january 2012 the fed started to
adhere to a 2 inflation target
and one of my favorite statistics is
that between
between that
january of 2012 and the
covet
they hit it in 11 months
they crossed that 2 target
and it stayed mainly below two percent
right which somehow was a failure
which i i don't understand
um
no because at two percent you you give
it 50 years and your dollar is worth
nothing so and that's a target that's a
goal well um
the the fed chairman at the time thought
that
ben bernanke thought a little inflation
prevented
deflation
and as uh
indebtedness builds up the worst thing
what we learned from the 30s is that the
worst thing is to have
deflation and high debts
it's a picture you're having you know
like a 500
000
dollar mortgage on your house and it's
worth 600 000
if it goes down to 400 000
your asset is deflated but your
liability is still the same that is why
debt deflation to me is
is what scares um
uh
policymakers them the most and it
probably should
and so
what they did they have a margin of
error of two percent well if you if you
miss it on the low side and and you
don't have deflation that to me is fine
it's not something to worry about i
agree with you yeah
against the target well
i i'm in favor of
inflation targeting for only one reason
it was
first adopted by the reserve bank of new
zealand
and my father is from new zealand
so being a kiwi at heart if they if if
they did it it must have been
doing something right but what
what is inflation
it's what's in the cpi to me does not
constitute the whole of inflation
the very sensible idea of
monetarism is that when there is too
much money it expresses itself in rising
prices
well if you it can be rising prices of
at the grocery store the gas station or
rent
but it also can be for assets
and for
not just stocks and
bonds nfts
i
i cannot get my head around the value of
an nft
no i don't really understand
blueprint for his home on mars
yeah well my my my son tried tries to
explain it to me and with that
together because there's some young
people going they don't understand
well yeah it's a
board yacht give me a torch
what is that
but that's the most
that's that's the big nft now
what and things like uh classic cars
and
i haven't i don't follow the art world
so much with more of a
car guy but
the the thing is they're bidding up
prices of
cars from when
jesus like me were young the cars that
we want to have and when they get into
six figures for very
really ordinary cars from back then
it means it's better to have that money
in that car because if you pay 150 000
for a 1970 olds 442
you you might be able to sell for 200
000 in a couple of years
as compared to having it in in the bank
and wasting away
and
that's also why uh you know billionaires
collect uh apartments at sky high in
manhattan it's like a
it's like a safe deposit box what you
want it in the bank wasting away or do
you want it to have
a thing even if you don't use it even if
you don't particularly like it but
whatever you whatever it's
the number on it today the number in a
couple years will be higher that's
to me evidence of more money not just
chasing
too few goods but
to about chasing a bunch of assets
and yet it's not captured in the cpi
data absolutely not and it even
something
cpi is supposed to be necessities
food clothing and shelter what they
stopped counting house prices directly
back when uh
don't hold me to the year but back in
the 70s back back when inflation was
first became a problem not not just came
back into the four
and now they have a cockamamie idea how
much would you pay to rent your own
house from yourself
only a doctoral level economist can come
up with that concept
whereas people
who want to buy a house obviously don't
buy a house every every month the way
you buy
you buy
food or or fill up your tank but uh on
the other hand
it is
part of the cost of living and you know
you might do buy a house every eight
years but everybody's buying there are
people buying houses every month and it
gives you an indication
of that there's excess liquidity chasing
this asset and the thing that makes my
head explode was we saw this right in
front of our faces especially last year
when uh that
we first were reading about the housing
bubble and people are you know jumping
and paying way over over the price and
the fed was buying
mortgage-backed securities to pump more
money
into mortgages they were
the fed was buying more mortgage-backed
securities than the mortgage
bankers were creating
so no wonder houses became unaffordable
but it didn't count in inflation
and
that this is um
this is
the problem that we have today
and then according to the st louis fed
we pumped 43.2 of gdp
into the u.s economy
yes we gave people tons of money
and you wonder why
supply
can't keep up with demand now we did
have a total
shock to the world the global system
and
it's
inflation isn't just
high in the u.s it is
even even germany it's over five percent
but um if if you
if you inject that amount of money into
the economy
what do you expect to happen except to
have higher prices
and in the end whom do those higher
prices benefit
everybody's chasing after trying to
get a raise to keep up
and that feels very familiar
that's that's why we have uh commendably
low unemployment that is the one success
that's come out i would never have
expected to have inflation below four
percent excuse me unemployment below
four percent
but
what is the need what was the need when
we saw unemployment coming way down
not to kind of
cut cut off the spigot right no i mean
that would have been the time to do it
yes and now we're
we're we're
kind of in a corner trying
you can't undo history but uh it would
have been a lot better
that if we had started this last year
when i don't know what the reluctance
was
made no sense
so
where do we go from here i mean it seems
like we're in the heat of an evolving
crisis i can't remember the last time
with russia ukraine china becoming
involved saudi arabia saber rattling
united arab emirates
this feels like something very different
than the other geopolitical
conflicts that we've had absolutely
to me it's imponderable where we go
because we
have so few options right now
we
the price of oil has gone way up but we
don't want to expand
the hydrocarbons because of
of climate concerns the one thing that
makes
no sense to me is the
we we do have a
a carbon-free source of energy
called nuclear
that um
has containable problems
and the idea that we can get
fr from here
to
net zero
uh overnight is just ludicrous and we're
going in just in terms of energy
we have to go through a very
uncomfortable transition period
of very expensive
energy we're going to be unfortunately
having to be
emitting more carbon than we want and
the the good thing is that i think
economics does work
price of a conventional energy will be
high enough to to accelerate further the
uh
the adoption of alternatives but we go
we we're going to have a population of
internal combustion engine
cars
for
another generation
sure so we can't get away from that i'd
like to transition but transition is not
instantaneous so
unfortunately every geopolitical crisis
since
the 70s since the yom kippur war since
um
since our involvement in uh iraq
and the the invasion of uh
of kuwait in the early 90s the first
the first desert storm i mean
has involved oil and the thing about oil
is that
those geological deposits are
in a certain place and it's usually in a
certain place where
people whose interests are inimical to
ours
are in charge
so to get away from that is um
i don't i wish i i had a a good answer
but we have we have fewer options we
have fewer options and i think our
optionality is also limited i'm not sure
what you think by the situation with
china
by our relationship with china yeah well
we we thought it was symbiotic
um
yeah okay well
they they uh provide
kind of vendor financing for us
uh
by buying our paper and we we give them
our paper and they send us our goods
the stuff that we want to buy our tvs
and stuff cheaply
and it it works until
[Music]
other considerations come in into
we are essentially
we are
a debtor
and
that that reduces our
our flexibility
um
i don't even want to think about what
happens in a conflict over the south
china sea
i don't know what
what example
the chinese take away from our actions
having to do with ukraine for for what
they
their ultimate plans for taiwan
um
[Music]
but i is the wake-up call yes well i
don't i don't i
i think the wake up is that uh
the west
has to be uh
we have to realize that the these are
other
they are not just our friends to trade
with that trade doesn't make
uh people more reasonable and
and friendly towards us
it can do uh just the opposite
uh and but the the good thing that's
come out of it is that even
germany has uh decided that it can
rid itself of some war guilt and
actually step up and
have a defense budget that's that's
needed
and that i think it it's clear
yes
we need our allies to clearly be our
allies yes and i think the
this was
a belated wake-up call that that has at
least gotten the allies on
a much the same page about about
how we
go forward whether
i hope that that it doesn't
result in any military
action on the part of the allies but
we have to be uh prepared and
you
you get strength i mean you get the
peace through
being a strong adversary and i think i
think um
i would say reagan proved that
and uh i
that that was kind of lost and frittered
away
so um
kind of kind of wrapping up the
discussion i'm curious because
the conventional wisdom is that
the world of alan greenspan holds
that the fed's going to be able to come
to the rescue come what may
whatever happens and yet we we're back
to having tangible innovation
and because of that tangible inflation i
think the fed's options are a lot fewer
than it had been
they could
after the dot com bust they could
inflate and bring bring down
uh fed funds rate to 1
okay eventually and
that led to the housing bubble
then after the great financial crisis we
had an extended period of low
ultra low interest rates
but again inflation at least officially
measured
did not get out of hand
now we have
at last count 7.9 cpi inflation and
uh we're just we last week we only
stopped
qe
only last week we were easing right up
until then
just uh in a day or so
the fed will raise the fed funds rate
off of
zero
that's all we've done
where where do we go if there is a
crisis we can negative interest rates i
one thing i i think is safe to predict
negative interest rates will never come
to the u.s
i don't think powell is your man i think
he'll hold that line yes
and uh i even though some
some very um learned economists think
that it's a good idea it just won't work
and i don't think it's worked well in
europe in japan they're the same ones
who tell you that your housing costs
have only gone up three percent yeah
well in in any case
given that we we can't just have the the
panacea of cheap money to bail us out
anymore what do we do i i really don't
know i think
inflation i the one thing i will agree
with the consensus is that inflation
will be lower at the end of the year
it'll be lower than 7.9 percent
whether it gets to uh below
four percent in the next two years i
kinda i kind of doubt it
therefore the fed had a lot of
flexibility with low inflation which
they took advantage of
maybe even abused arguably
and
they don't have that now
and
on the fiscal side
having a um
debt to debt to gdp uh ratio over a
hundred percent also constrains yourself
my uh
it's 133 it was 31 in 1970 yes and
volker took office yes and so actually
we didn't have a problem and the only
reason it has been a problem is that
it's being
uh financed and it's still at legacy
rates of one percent or so
or less for
most of uh
the short end of the yield curve where
the those uh
short term notes that and they will roll
off and eventually even if it's at two
percent which is historically low and
negative in real terms it'll still be
higher um
i think people understand how much
how much we save so to speak an interest
expense as a country uncle sam yeah
because he's had these artificially low
interest rates for generations
yeah and uh actually we can
pile on a lot of debt uh
everywhere because it's cheap
and
if
if we used it for productive purposes
that would be great but a lot of it has
been just to maintain current spending
so i would never take out a
30-year mortgage to go on a on a
vacation
but to buy a a house that i'll live in
for
decades that that makes sense but we
don't have anything to show for it we
the the country's falling apart and we
can see that and we're deep in in the
hole
so
i'm sorry if i don't have
i have a great
i don't have a great uh
answer for that and the other thing is
we're going to have to spend more for
our defense
leaving less for everything
else that's yet another wake-up call
but
you know we can hope for strong
leadership going forward at the fed
and inside the beltway i mean we can
hopefully
say that this maybe is a change agent to
bring about a new crop of
of leaders for america maybe maybe we
can hope for that
we can hope i i'm not
optimistic that a will
i think
to get the problem solved you need
people coming together with compromise
and that's the farthest thing that from
what we have now yep true
well
we'll see i mean i've usually got the
black cloud over my head but well we're
bond people that's what
yeah
that's that's that's the one thing that
i see people apparently
no we we don't believe we we want to
actually get our our money back which
gives us a kind of a a different
viewpoint on things that
i i agree is
sometimes not optimistic enough
that's my big failing
yes but it's very entertaining to read
oh well so
i'm i'm glad i appreciate that your
column is is around and i enjoy it
now i get it on friday nights instead of
saturday mornings
so
but thank you so much i really
appreciate you taking all this time
today
and taking us back down memory lane to
one generation of inflation to go to two
generations of inflation
and now we've brown tripped so thank you
randy thank you
you